هي الرحله الاولى لخالد في بدايه دراسته
الجامعيه
لكن الوصول الى كليه العلوم في الجامعه
اللبنانيه الرسميه ليس بالمهمه السهله
ذلك ان انتقاله من شمال لبنان الى بيروت
سيكلفه شهريا نصف راتب والده سكن في
اهلي فيني اعطوني المصاري الي عم تكلفه
يوم يومين بس ما فيني كافي اكيد بهذا
الشيء
تامين تكاليف الوصول الى الجامعه هو تحدي
بالنسبه الى خالد وزملائه ليس وحدهم من
يعانون
فاساتذتهم يكابدون بتامين كلفه الانتقال
وزياده ثلاثه اضعاف الراتب التي ستمنحها
الحكومه للاساتذه لن تكفيهم بعد تراجع
مدخولهم خلال السنوات الثلاث الماضيه
بثلاثه الاف الى نحو 300 دولار جر انهيار
سعر صرف العمله الوطنيه
ورجعنا مع انه ما اخذنا شيء انتبهتوا علي
كيف ليه لان هو لي ولادنا اورايد بس
بالنهايه لا سمح الله انا اذا صار لي شيء
يمكن ما قادره اطبل بعد شوي انا ماشي يمكن
ما يؤديني بدل ناقل
العدد الاكبر من طلاب لبنان
وتتوزع فروعها على مختلف
لكن الازمه الاقتصاديه ادت الى تراجع كبير
في موازنتها التي تؤمنها الحكومه
اللبنانيه وهو ما يشكل مخاطره تتهدد
مستقبل التعليميه لطلابها كلمه
ونحصل الاموال اللي وعدت الدوله
من ناحيه التسهيلات والتامين الحاجات
يبقى عنا اهم لازم نحاول نعالجه له علاقه
بتحسين رواتب الاساسي والموظفين
لكنه لا يعني حكما استمراره دون اضرابات
او تعطيل قصري تقول اداره الجامعه انها
تعمل على قاعده المعالجه وفق ما هو متاح
لتطويق الازمات التي قد يسببها اي تدهور
اضافي للعمله الوطنيه
يعتقد كثيرون من اساتذه وطلاب ان الجامعه
تعمل وسط ازمه ماليه لم تشهدها من قبل وان
اي تفاق من جديد لها قد يعطل العام
الدراسي وقدره الجامعه على تامين الكهرباء
وتشغيل وصيانتي مبانيها ايهاب العقد
الجزيره بيروت